hey everyone I'm Richard here today
taking a look at the radian rx470 so I
rather like the rx480 it just offers
great performance for its Target price
point specifically the $200 4 gig model
but curiously these seem rather thin on
the ground now and now I think I know
why the rx470 is basically a direct
replacement with very very similar
levels of performance so we've got two
models here an XFX version and an m SI
model both of which are Factory
overclocked out of the box now the XFX
version seems to be running with faster
memory and ever so slightly higher core
clocks so as you can see here in this
Crisis 3 Benchmark that's the swifter
card but there's only like one or two
frames per second in it hardly Earth
shattering stuff and actually given the
choice I'd take the MSI model in a
heartbeat the build quality is marketly
higher and the Acoustics are just on
another level especially useful when it
comes to overclocking the core inputs
and outputs seem to be much the same
though with a very similar Port
Arrangement uh dual link DVI display
port and HDMI 2.0 but there is a
difference in terms of power delivery
the MSI model has an 8pin power input
whereas the XFX model has the six pin
input that's standard to this board now
in theory this means that you should be
able to pump more power through the MSI
rx470 but in practice you're going to be
hitting the limit of the processor
before that happens okay then so let's
kick off by taking a look at performance
both the MSI and the XFX models we have
hit boost Targets in the 1240 to 1250
MHz range meaning the fluctuating boosts
we saw on the reference rx480 aren't an
issue here the end result is that both
of these cards get very very close to
the 480 we tested so this is Crisis 3
and here we're comparing the 470 with
both versions of the reference 480 we're
less than 1 FPS behind the 4 Gig 480 and
2 FPS off the target set by the 8 gig
card however it's interesting to note
that all of the Polaris products fall
short of the outgoing r9390 in this test
it's 5 FPS faster than the 480 and 7 FPS
faster than the 470 okay then but things
change up when we take a look at the
division it's a really interesting
Benchmark the 470 is 2 FPS off the pace
set by the 4 Gig 480 and 3 to 4 FPS
short of the 8 gig model however check
out the r9390 showing generally speaking
it is the faster card out of all of them
but in this game the Polaris products
all of them including the rx470 are
faster now that's not bad at all bearing
in mind the frankly colossal power
saving Advantage now let's move on to
rise of the Tomb Raider here very high
quality High textures dx12 once again
just 1 frame per second difference
between the MSI 470 we tested and the 4
Gig 480 with a 2 FPS differential with a
390 and the 8 gig 480 so I think the
point is clear the rx470 has slower
memory and four fewer compute units than
the top tier Polaris 480 but some might
say that the performance differential is
kind of almost Irrelevant in actual
gameplay the end user experience on
games that will happily occupy 4 gigs of
RAM is essentially identical and in fact
you can overclock the 470 to go faster
than either 480 the MSI model saw the
core increase by 9% which is really
impressive while we pushed Ram as far as
it could go well that was only 6.8 GB
per second unfortunately but still the
results speak for themselves in all
cases we're either ahead or on par with
the 8 gig rx480 so here's Assassin's
Creed Unity from being 4% behind the 480
we're now 4% ahead next up check out
Hitman dx12 now this is an example of
how the rx470 overclock basically brings
us up to par with the the 480 lovely
stuff but I think the real takeaway here
is that the RX 470 well let's be frank
here it's not actually that much slower
than the 480 at stock speeds and
remember that the XFX version well it
might be louder but it's also a bit
quicker than the MSI model here too and
actually well let's think about this for
a second if I have two RX 470s well why
not run them in crossfire how does that
work out well as usual it all depends on
the game at its best 2 470s in crossfire
can be brutally fast so let's aim our
sights really high here and Stack Up
Crossfire 470 with GTX 1070 and GTX 1080
first up Assassin's Creed Unity yeah
we're sitting between the two Nvidia
heavyweights here and in fact we're
closer to the GTX 1080 Crisis 3 well
that's not known for its multi-gpu
scalability so it lags behind both of
the more expensive Nvidia cards Far Cry
Primal well that's more in GTX 1070
terod fee as long as you handle your
vram so you're under the 4 Gig limit
you're good to go but well the thing
about multi-gpu whether it's NVIDIA SLI
or AMD Crossfire well it's not
particularly reliable some games don't
scale well at all some games don't even
support the feature at all meaning
you've got a spare GPU sitting there
doing absolutely nothing and sometimes
the results can look great on paper and
in terms of benchmarks but the real life
experience really sucks so hey The
Witcher 3 in 470 Crossfire runs at an
average of 86 FPS that's not so far
behind the GTX 1070 at 94 FPS but check
out the frame times that is indeed the
legendary micro stutter well it's
actually more like macro stutter in the
case of The Witcher 3 because you
literally can't avoid seeing it okay
then so yeah Crossfire 470 it's an
option but I would always advise on one
more powerful GPU as a opposed to two
lesser models running in parallel okay
then so there we go I rather liked the
rx480 the 4 Gig model in particular at
$200 represents Great Value but
availability Where It's Curious it seems
to be a bit of a problem particularly if
you want to avoid the reference design I
mean as far as I know Sapphire do a 4
gig model but that's it compare and
contrast with the rx470 there's no
shortage of them you can take your pick
from a bunch of great thermal Solutions
and the performance wow for
$180 this is an excellent product 1080p
60 FPS console level settings or better
right then this is your boy okay then so
that's that do like and subscribe if you
found the video useful and I'll catch
you next
time